voters in georgia are turning their
backs on president biden as we get
closer to the midterm elections a new
poll shows biden's job approval rating
in the key swing state has plunged to 34
a sharp decline from may when it was 51
that's a whopping 62 percent now
disapproving karl rove is a former white
house deputy chief of staff and a fox
news contributor when you see a number
like that carl what do you think
if i'm a democrat i say oh something or
other and if i'm a republican i say wow
uh that that that portends a real
problem for senator warnock the democrat
who's up this fall
and a good chance for republicans to
take the senate seat there and thereby
change in the composition of the senate
there was another one from the ajc the
general constitution out of atlanta
right track wrong track direction 71
percent say wrong track
how much weight do you give that now
i give it a lot because that's
emblematic of what's happening
nationwide if you look at the real clear
politics average it's in the high 60s
thinking the country's off on the wrong
direction and just over a quarter of the
population saying that they think the
country's going on the right track that
if you're the incumbent party you want
that number to be a heck of a lot better
than it is today because
people are going to hold the democrats
who are in charge of washington the
presidency the house and the senate
they're going to hold them accountable
for the direction of the country yeah i
just want to say the biggest rock was
among independents as well and we always
watch that
who are going to be the swing voters who
decide the fall election so
a big problem for the democrats do you
think this transfers to other swing
states as well like pennsylvania
oh sure in fact look when you have that
kind of a number nationwide you're going
to see it replicated in virtually every
state and absolutely i've seen data from
north carolina and pennsylvania and
arizona and nevada all of which would
indicate that there you know all of
which have high profile statewide races
for the governor and senator uh except
north carolina has a senate race no
governor race and but
they're indicative of the same kind of
thing democrats are in trouble and
there's not much that's going to change
that
between now and november we were looking
at your piece this morning wall street
journal from k rove if only bernie
sanders were more blunt
and the subheader is the state of the
gop and democrats was encapsulated by
two senators speeches
um what did you hear
well bernie sanders went on meet the
press and and you know attacked the
president of the united states of his
party
and the democratic leader of the senate
saying their strategy of trying to get
cinema and and uh
senator manchin to flip on the bill back
better and on voting rights legislation
killing the filibuster was an utter
failure and that they had to have a
change of course that change of course
is split the build back better bill up
bring it up one
big measure at a time and make the
republicans vote against it and have the
democrats vote for it the problem is
that that is gonna is gonna draw
attention to the big problems inside the
buildback better bill namely we got 10
years of revenue to support one year of
the child tax credit or three or four
years of of the the affordable care
subsidies or five or six years of pre-k
in other words we're we're using
gimmicks to hide the true cost of the
bill so let's bring that bill up and let
let the republicans vote against it and
democrats vote for it and it's going to
hurt them at the polls in the fall
because our concern is about inflation
that's being driven by too much
government spending particularly reading
spending all right then carl just
quickly before we lose you uh there's a
supreme court nomination that president
biden is going to be able to do now what
do you say to folks who think that this
is a big turnaround point for president
biden and a really big boost for the
democrats
look i get it uh he gets to fulfill a
pledge to appoint a black woman it's a
they get to change the subject and stop
talking about things that are hurting
them it's a big important thing the
supreme court
partisans on both sides the democrats
will be unified but i would just remind
them these same things were in stage in
2006 when the republicans
when a republican president could
nominate sam alito and it didn't stop us
from losing the midterm elections this
is not going to have a huge impact on
the fall elections it's not going to be
a big advantage to the democrats it's a
temporary uh resp you know retreat from
the from the brutal battles that they've
suffered the last year and lost but it's
not going to save them in the fall
elections people are concerned about
jobs and inflation in the economy lots
of other things the supreme court
nomination is going to going to be far
in the rear view mirror by the time we
get to it you just gave me like one of
those flashbacks of how busy it was from
august of 2005 till february of 2006 and
beyond that was quite a time thanks carl
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now